it was well armed with retractable claws
on both attends and its feet
it's bum claws were particularly well
developed some people think of these as
actual killing weapons but the marsupial
I'm actually went in and sliced and
diced its brain opened it up with the
claws and that they might then have bled
to death I think that's pretty unlikely
in reality these massive thumb claws I
think would have been used as grappling
holes but not everyone agrees that
Thaler Kaleo has the ability to be a
lethal killer or to defend itself
against human predators one of its
features is especially puzzling
it's teeth
at first look phylla kaleo's teeth don't
resemble those of a typical carnivore
so dr. Roe is putting the creature to
the ultimate test he scans a complete
skull of a small thigh luckily Oh from
the South Australian Museum then he
sends the data to his colleagues at the
University of Western Australia using a
technique known as rapid prototyping
they build a full sized cast of the
skull and jaw prototyping uses computer
modeling to create paper-thin
cross-sections of the skull a
high-powered co2 laser beam then melts
metal powder into each of the thousands
of layers until it finally builds a
bronze cast
in collaboration with the University of
Newcastle in New South Wales
Doctorow designs a method to estimate
the bite force of the marsupial lion
they conduct a series of experiments
using computer modeling and a sheep's
head
first of all we've had these large
incisors at the front penetrate the
flesh between those upper and lower
incisors it's pulled the neck of the
animal back into those massive slicing
teeth at the back and this is a
relatively small marsupial on skull the
bite of even a small phyla Kaleo
generates 1,000 pounds of force close to
that of a female lion an animal double
its size pound for pound the thigh
locally owes bite is nearly twice as
powerful as any big cat today
you